[Music]
hey minimizers you're getting ready to
watch some footage from one of the
minimalist live events from the love
people use things tour if you'd like to
see us on the road visit
theminimalists.com
tour or you can find all of our live
events over at patreon.com slash the
minimalists enjoy
howdy what's your name hi my name is
noor hey north very quickly just wanna
share i don't know a lot of people here
so i bought myself a table to come here
at the last minute i invited a co-worker
she has no idea who you guys are about
five minutes in she leans over to me and
says as someone whose cat has their own
wardrobe i don't think i belong here
get out
i'm joking please don't
so about four months ago i
got a job which was my object a
two months ago my relationship ended
and not necessarily because of that but
just long distance sucks
he has now become my object a i really
realized how much i value having him in
my life what a wonderful person he is i
feel that he
complements me very well and i really
respect and find comfort in the way that
you both speak about your partners so my
question is when you met your partners
were they your object day
yeah what a wonderful question
the answer is no
um
and
what i can tell you is that um
i talked about this with respect to
stuff earlier but the objects of our
desire become the objects of our
discontent
and my guess is there one or two times
you were discontented in that
relationship right absolutely yeah that
that's generally how relationships go so
that's one pithy thing for you but
here's something else to make it this is
pithily depressing um
every relationship in your life will
make you miserable
and so choose
your relationships carefully
because you're ultimately choosing your
you're you're choosing your own misery
now of course it's
your own expectations that make you
miserable it's not the other person it's
never the other person
no person in your life in this room has
the ability
to make you upset
only you make you upset
yeah i'd my opinion is just something
similar what he was saying it's
uh a person can
enhance your life
but they can't
make your life
i don't know if that makes sense you
can't complete your life yeah can't
complete your life thank you
yeah it's the that's the most insidious
thing the jerry maguire thing right you
complete me
that presupposes you're incomplete so
you're already complete
and if he can augment your life
wonderful you can enjoy him
you can love him you can see him for who
he is without trying to change him how
beautiful is that
but the moment you have an expectation
that's really a desire to change someone
and you'll get dragged by every
expectation you have
yeah long distance sucks uh i met mariah
in october
uh 2013. i left for tour
for a year january 2014.
and
it sucked
but i mean we kept in touch we kept the
long distance thing going
um
there was something i was looking for
specifically and looking for a partner
and she fulfilled that i don't know if i
would call her mom maybe she was my
object day i don't know
um i don't
because because yeah i was definitely
looking for something but i guess all
i'm trying to say is like if it's
for mariah and i i just kind of and i
think she took the same approach if it
was meant to be then it would work out
over that year of us being away and it
did work out and i'm incredibly grateful
for that
thanks for your question yeah thanks
thank you
did you enjoy this video if so you can
listen to full episodes of the
minimalist private podcast available
exclusively on patreon visit patreon.com
the minimalists today your support keeps
our podcast and youtube channel 100
percent advertisement free